The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So last
time we started
talking about superfluid helium.
And we said that the
phase diagram of helium-4,
the isotope that is a boson
has the following interesting
properties.
First of all, helium
stays a liquid
all the way down
to 0 temperature
because of the combinations
of its light mass and heat
interactions.
And secondly, that [INAUDIBLE]
to cool down helium
through this process
of evaporated cooling,
one immediately observes
something interesting
happening at temperatures
below 2 degrees
Kelvin, where it becomes
this superfluid that
has a number of
interesting properties.
And in particular as
pertaining to viscosity,
we made two observations.
First of all, you can
make these capillaries--
and I'll show you been
movie in more detail later
on where it flows through
capillaries as if there
is no resistance
and there is nothing
that sticks to the walls
of the capillaries.
It flows without
viscosity, whereas there
was this experiment of
Andronikashvili, in which you
had something that
was oscillating
and you were calculating
how much of the helium
was stuck to the plates
of the container.
And the result was
something like this,
that is there was a decrease
in the amount of fluid
that is stuck to the plates.
But it doesn't go
immediately down to 0.
It has a kind of
form such as this
that I will draw more
clearly now and explain.
So what we did last time was
to note that people observed
that there were
some similarities
between this
superfluid transition
and Bose-Einstein condensation.
But what I would
like to highlight
in the beginning
of this lecture is
that there are also very
important differences.
So let's think about
these distinctions
between Bose-Einstein condensate
add the superfluid helium.
One set of things we would
like to take from the picture
that I have over there, which
is diffraction of the fluid that
is stuck to the plates
and in some sense
behaves like a normal fluid.
Now let me make the analogy
to Bose-Einstein condensation.
You know that in the
Bose-Einstein condensation
there was also this phenomenon
that there was a separation
into two parts of
the total density.
And be regarded as a
function of temperature
some part of the density as
belonging to the normal state.
So when you are above
Tc of n, everything
is essentially normal.
And then what happens is
that when you hit Tc of n
you can no longer put
all of the particles
that you have in
the excited states.
So the fraction that goes
in the excited states
goes down and eventually
goes to 0 at 0 temperature.
And essentially, this would
be the reverse of the curve
that we have in that
figure over there.
Basically, there's
a portion that
would be the normal part that
would be looking like this.
Now, the way that we
obtained this result
was that basically there
was a fraction that
was in the normal state.
The part that was
excited was described
by this simple formula that was
g over lambda cubed [INAUDIBLE]
of 3/2.
So it went to 0 as T to the 3/2.
So basically, the
proportionality
here is T to the 3/2.
And then basically,
the curve would
come down here and
go to 0 linearly.
Now what is shown
in the experiment
is that the curve
actually goes to 0
in a much more sharp fashion.
And actually, when people try
to fit a curve through this,
the curve looks something like
Tc minus T to the 2/3 over.
But also it goes to 0 much
more rapidly than the curve
that we have for
Bose-Einstein condensation.
Indeed, it goes through
0 proportionately to T
to the fourth.
And so that's something that we
need to understand and explain.
Now all of the properties of
the Bose-Einstein condensate
was very easy to
describe once we realized
that all of the things that
correspond to excitation,
such as the energy,
heat capacity,
pressure, come from
this fraction that
is in the excited state.
And we can calculate,
say, the contribution
to energy heat
capacity, et cetera.
And in particular, if we look
at the behavior of the heat
capacity as a function
of temperature,
for this Bose-Einstein
condensate, the behavior
that we had was that again
simply at low temperatures
it was going proportionately
to T to the 3/2,
because this was the number
of excitations that you had.
So these two T to the
3/2 are very much related
to each other.
And then this curve would
basically go along its way
until it hit Tc of
n at some point.
And we separately
calculated the behavior
coming from high temperatures.
And the behavior from
high temperatures
would start with
the classical result
that the heat capacity
is 3/2 per particle
due to the kinetic energy that
you can put in these things.
And then it would rise, and it
would then join this curve over
here.
Now when you look at the
actual heat capacity,
indeed the shape up
the heat capacity
is the thing that gives this
transition the name of a lambda
transition.
It kind of looks like a lambda.
And at Tc there are
divergences approaching
from the two sides that
behave like the log.
And again more
importantly, what we
find is that at
0 temperature, it
doesn't go through 0, the
heat capacity as T to the 3/2,
but rather as T to
the third power.
So the red curve
corresponds to superfluid,
the green curve corresponds
to Bose-Einstein condensate.
And so they're clearly
different from each other.
So that's what we would
like you to understand.
Well the thing that is easiest
to understand and figure out
is the difference between
these heat capacities.
And the reason for that
is that we had already
seen a form that was of
the heat capacity that
behaved like T cubed.
That was when we were looking
at phonons in a solid.
So let's remind
you why was it that
for the Bose-Einstein
condensate we
were getting this T
to the 3/2 behavior?
The reason for that was that
the various excitations,
I could plot as a function
of k, or p, which is h bar k.
They're very much
related to each other.
And for the
Bose-Einstein condensate,
the form was simply
a parabola, which
is this p squared over
2 mass of the helium.
Let's say, assuming that
what we are dealing with
is non-interacting particles
with mass of helium.
And this parabolic
curve essentially
told us that various quantities
behave as T to the 3/2.
Roughly, the idea is that
at some temperature that
has energy of the order
of kT, you figure out
how far you have excited things.
And since this
form is a parabola,
the typical p is going to
scale like T to the 1/2.
You have a volume in three
dimensions in p space.
If the radius goes
like T to the 1/2,
the volume goes
like T to the 3/2.
That's why you have all kinds
of excitations such as this.
And the reason for the
Bose-Einstein condensation
was that you would start to fill
out all of these excitations.
And when you were adding all
of the mean occupation numbers,
the answer was not
coming up all the way
to the total number
of particles.
So then you have to put
an excess at p close
to 0, which corresponds to the
ground state of this system.
Now of course when
you look at helium,
helium molecules, helium
atoms have the interactions
between them that we discussed.
In particular, you can't really
put them on top of each other.
There is a hard exclusion
when you bring things
close to each other.
So the ground
state of the system
must look very different
from the ground state
of the Bose-Einstein condensate
in which the particles freely
occupy the entire box.
So there is a very
difficult story
associated with
figuring out what
the ground state of this
combination of interacting
particles that make
up liquid helium is.
What is the behavior?
What's the many-body wave
function at 0 temperature?
Now as we see here, in order
to understand the heat capacity
we really don't
need to know what
is happening at
the ground state.
What we need to know in
order to find heat capacity
is how to put more energy in the
system above the ground state.
So we need to know
something about excitations.
And so that's the
perspective that Landau took.
Landau said, well, this is
the spectrum of excitations
if you had [? plain ?] particles
without any interactions.
Let's imagine what
happens if we gradually
tune in the interactions,
the particles
start to repel each
other, et cetera.
This non-interacting
ground state
that we had in which the
particles were uniformly
distributed across
the system will
evolve into some complicated
ground state I don't know.
And then, presumably
there would be a spectrum
of excitations around
that ground state.
Now the excitations around
the non-interacting ground
state we can label by
this momentum peak.
And it kind of
makes sense that we
should be able to have a
singular label for excitations
around the ground state of
these interacting particles.
And this is where
you sort of needed
a little bit of Landau's
type of insight.
He said, well,
presumably what you
do when you have
excitations of momentum p
is to distort the wave
function in a manner that
is consistent with having these
kind of excitations of momentum
p.
And he said, well
we typically know
that if you have
a fluid or a solid
and we want to impart some
momentum above the ground
state, if will go in
the form of phonons.
These are distortions in
which the density will
vary in some sinusoidal or
cosine way across the system.
So he said that maybe
what is happening
is that for these
excitations you
have to take what ever this
interacting ground state is--
which we don't know and
can't write that down--
but hope that
excitations around it
correspond to these
distortions in density.
And that by analogy with
what happens for fluids,
that the spectrum of excitations
will then become a linear.
You would have something
like a sound wave
that you would have in
a liquid or a solid.
So if you do this, if you
have a linear spectrum
then we can see what happen.
For a particular energy
of the order of kT,
we will go here,
occupied momenta that
would be of the order
of kT over H bar.
The number of excitations would
be something like this cubed,
and so you would
imagine that you
would get a heat capacity that
is proportional to this times
kB.
And if you do things
correctly, like really
for the case of
phonons or photons,
you can even figure out what
the numerical prefactor is here.
And there's a velocity
here because this curve
goes like H bar vP.
So then you can
compare what you have
over here with the coefficient
of the T cubed over here,
and you could even figure
out what this velocity is.
And it turns out to be of the
order of 240 meters per second.
A typical sound wave that
you would have in a fluid.
So that's kind of
a reasonable thing.
Now of course, when you go
to higher and higher momenta,
it corresponds to essentially
shorter and shorter
wavelengths.
You expect that when
you get wavelengths
that is of the order of
the interatomic spacing,
then the interactions become
less and less important.
You have particles
rattling in a cage
that is set up by
everybody else.
And then you should regain
this kind of spectrum
at high values of momentum.
And so what Landau
did was he basically
joined these things
together and posed
that there is a spectrum
such as this that
has what is called
a phonon part, which
is this linear part where
energy goes like H bar,
like the velocity
times the momentum.
And it has a part that in
the vicinity of this point,
you can expand parabolically.
And it's called rotons.
There is a gap
delta, and then H bar
squared over 2, some effective
mass, k minus k0 squared.
This k0 turns out to
be roughly of the order
of the inverse
[INAUDIBLE], two Angstrom
inverse, between particles.
This mu is of the order
of mass of [INAUDIBLE].
So about 10 years
or so after Landau,
people are able to get to this
whole spectrum of excitation
through neutron scattering
and other scattering
types of experiments.
And so this picture
was confirmed.
So, yes?
AUDIENCE: What is a
roton? [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Over here
what you are seeing
is essentially particles
rattling in the cage.
It is believed that
what is happening here
are collections of
three or four atoms that
are kind of rotating
in a bigger cage.
So something, the
picture that people draw
is three or four
particles rotating around.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there
some [INAUDIBLE] curve
where energy's
decreasing [INAUDIBLE]?
Does the transition between
photon and roton [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: There is no
thermodynamic or other rule
that says that the energy should
be one of [INAUDIBLE] momentum
that I know.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there an
expression for that k0
in terms of temperature and
other properties of the system?
PROFESSOR: This
curve of excitations
is supposed to be property
of the ground state.
That is, you take this
system in its ground state,
and then you create
an excitation that
has some particular
momentum and calculate
what the energy of that is.
Actually, this whole
curve is phenomenological,
because in order to get
the excitations you better
have an expression for
what the ground state is.
And so writing a
kind of wave function
that describes the ground state
of this interacting system
is a very difficult task.
I think Feynman has some
variational type of wave
function that we can start
and work with, and then
calculate things approximately
in terms of that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What inspired
Landau to propose
that there was a [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Actually,
it was not so much
I think looking at
this curve, but which
I think if you
want to match that
and that, you have to
have something like this.
But this was really that the
whole experimental version
of the heat capacity,
it didn't seem
like this expression
was sufficient.
And then there was some amount
of excitation and energy
at the temperatures that were
experimentally accessible
that heated at the presence
of the rotons in the spectrum.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So
continuing [INAUDIBLE],
if you raise the thermal energy
kBT, [INAUDIBLE] level where
you have multiple
roots of this curve.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So you will be
able to excite some states
and have some kind of gap, like
a gap of momenta which are not.
PROFESSOR: OK, so at any
finite temperatures-- and I'll
do the calculation for
you shortly-- there
is a finite probability for
exciting all of these states.
What you are saying
is that when there
is more occupation at this
momentum compared to that,
but much less compared to this.
So that again does not
violate any condition.
So it is like, again, trying to
shake this system of particles.
Let's imagine that
you have grains,
and you are trying
to shake them.
And it may be that at
some shaking frequencies,
then there are things
that are taking place
at short distances in
addition to some waves
that you're generating.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the methodology
of getting this
spectrum, because if we
have a experimental result
of the [INAUDIBLE] capacity,
then if we assume
there's a spectrum,
there has to be
this one, because it
gives a one to one
correspondence.
So we can get the spectrum
directly from the c.
So--
PROFESSOR: I'm not sure,
because in reality this
is going to be spectrum in
three-dimensional space.
And there is certainly
an expression
that relates the heat capacity
to the excitation spectrum.
What I'm not sure is
whether mathematically
that expression
uniquely invertible.
It is given an epsilon-- c,
you have a unique epsilon of p.
Certainly, given an epsilon
of p, you have a unique c.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: But if the excitation
spectrum only depends on,
let's say, k squared, not on
the three-dimensional components
of k, then maybe
it's much easier
to draw a one to
one correspondence?
PROFESSOR: I don't
know, because you
have a function of
temperature and you
want to convert it to
a function of momentum
that after some
integrations will give you
that function of temperature.
I don't know the difficulty
of mathematically doing that.
I know that I can't off my head
think of an inversion formula.
It's not like the function
that you're inversing.
So the Landau spectrum
can explain this part.
It turns out that the Landau
spectrum cannot explain this
logarithmic divergence.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, one
more question about this.
The allowed values of
k, do they get modified,
or are they thought
to be the same?
PROFESSOR: No.
So basically at some point,
I have to change perspective
from a sum over k to an integral
over k or an integral over p.
The density of
states in momentum
is something that is
kind of invariant.
It is a very slight
function of shape.
So the periodic
boundary conditions
and the open boundary
conditions, et cetera,
give you something slightly
different over here.
But by the time you
go to the continuum,
it's a property
of dimension only.
It doesn't really depend
on the underlying shape.
AUDIENCE: So we
still change sums
for integrals with
the same rules?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
It's a sort of general
density of state property.
So there's some nice
formula that tells you
what the density of state
is for an arbitrary shape,
and the leading term is
always proportional to volume
or area [INAUDIBLE]
the density of state
that you have been calculating.
And then there are
some leading terms
that are proportional to
if it is volume to area,
or number of edges, et cetera.
But those are kind of subleading
the thermodynamic sense.
So I guess Feynman
did a lot of work
on formalizing these
ideas of Landau getting
some idea of what the ground
state does, is, and excitations
that you can have
about the spectrum.
And so he was very
happy at being
able to explain this,
including the nature of rotons,
et cetera.
And he was worried
that somehow he
couldn't get this
logarithmic divergence.
And that bothered
him a little bit,
but Onsager told him
that that's really
a much more fundamental
property that
depends on critical phenomena,
and for resolving that issue,
you have to come to 8.334.
So we will not discuss
that, nor will we
discuss why this is Tc minus
T to the 2/3 power and not
a linear dependence.
It again is one of these
critical properties.
But we should be able to
explain this T to the fourth.
And clearly, this
T to the fourth
is not as simple as saying this
exponent changed from 3/2 to 3,
this 3/2 should
also change the 3.
No, it went to T to the fourth,
so what's going on over here?
So last time at the
end of the lecture
I wrote a statement that
the BEC is not superfluid.
And what that really
means is that it
has too many excitations,
low energy excitations.
So imagine the
following, that maybe we
have a container-- I don't
know, maybe we have a tube--
and we have our superfluid going
through this with velocity v
sub s.
We want it to maintain that
velocity without experiencing
friction, which it
seems to do in going
through these capillaries.
You don't have to push it, it
seems to be going by itself.
And so the question is,
can any of these pictures
that we drew for excitations
be consistent with this?
Now, why am I talking about
excitations and consistency
with superfluid?
Because what can
happen in principle
is that within your system,
you can spontaneously
generate some excitation.
This excitation will
have some momentum p
and some energy epsilon of p.
And if you spontaneously can
create these excitations that
would take away energy from this
kinetic energy of the flowing
superfluid, gradually the
superfluid will slow down.
Its energy will be
dissipated and the superfluid
itself will heat up
because you generated
these excitations with it.
So let's see what happens.
If I were to create
such an excitation,
actually I have to worry
about momentum conservation
because I created something
that carried momentum p.
Now initially, let's say
that this whole entity, all
of the fluid that are
superflowing with velocity Vs
have mass M. So the initial
momentum would be MVs.
Now, I created some
excitation that
is carrying away
some momentum p.
So the only thing that
can ensure this happens
is that I have to
slightly change
the velocity of the fluid.
Now this change in
velocity is infinitesimal.
It is Vs minus p
divided by M. M is huge,
so why bother
thinking about this?
Well, let's see what
the change in energy is.
Delta E. Let's say, well,
you created this excitation
so you have energy epsilon of p.
But I say, in
addition to that there
is a change in the kinetic
energy of the superfluid.
I'm now moving at
Vs prime squared,
whereas initially when this
excitation was not present,
I was moving at Vs.
And so what do you have here?
We have epsilon of p, M
over 2 Vs minus p over M,
this infinitesimal change
in velocity squared minus M
over 2 Vs squared.
We can see that the leading
order of the kinetic energy
goes away, but that there
is a cross term here
in which the M contribution--
the contribution of the mass--
goes away.
And so the change in energy is
actually something like this.
So if I had a system that
when stationary, the energy
to create an excitation of
momentum p was epsilon of p,
when I put that in a frame that
is moving with some velocity
Vs, you have the
ability to borrow
some of that kinetic energy
and the excitation energy
goes down by this amount.
So what happens if I take
the Bose-Einstein type
of excitation spectrum
that is p squared over 2M
and then subtract
a v dot p from it?
Essentially there is a
linear subtraction going on,
and I would get a
curve such as this.
So I probably exaggerated
this by a lot.
I shouldn't have
subtracted so much.
Let me actually not
subject so much,
because we don't want to go
all the way in that range.
But you can see that there
is a range of momenta where
you would spontaneously gain
energy by creating excitations.
If the spectrum was
initially p squared over 2M,
basically you just have too
many low energy excitations.
As soon as you
start moving it, you
will spontaneously
excite these things.
Even if you were initially
at 0 temperature,
these phonon excitations
would be created spontaneously
in your system.
They would move
all over the place.
They would heat up your system.
There is no way
that you can pass
the Bose-Einstein
condensate-- actually,
there's no way that you can even
move it without losing energy.
But you can see that
this red curve does not
have that difficulty.
If I were to shift this curve
by an amount that is linear,
what do I get?
I will get something like this.
So the Landau spectrum
is perfectly fine
as far as excitations
is concerned.
At zero temperature, even if the
whole fluid is moving then it
cannot spontaneously
create excitations,
because you would increase
energy of the system.
So there's this difference.
Ultimately, you would
say that the first time
you would get excitation is
if you move it fast enough
so that some portion of
this curve goes to 0.
And indeed, if you were
to try to stir or move
a superfluid fast
enough, there's
a velocity at which
it breaks down,
it stops being a superfluid.
But it turns out that that
velocity is much, much smaller
than you would predict based on
this roton spectrum going down.
There are some other
many body excitations
that come before and cause
the superfluid to lose energy
and break down.
But the genetic idea as
to why a linear spectrum
for k close to 0 is
consist with superfluidity
but the quadratic one
is not remains correct.
Now suppose I am
in this situation.
I have a moving super
fluid, such as the one
that I have described over here.
The spectrum is going to
be somewhat like this,
but I'm not at 0 temperature.
I want to try to describe
this T to the fourth behavior,
so I want to be at some
finite temperature.
So if I'm at some
finite temperature,
there is some probability to
excite these different states,
and the number that would
correspond to some momentum p
would be given by this
general formula you have,
1 over Z inverse e to the
beta epsilon of p minus 1.
Furthermore, if I think that
I am in the regime where
the number of excitations
is not important because
of the same reason that I had
for Bose-Einstein condensate,
I would have this formula
except that I would use epsilon
of p that is appropriate
to this system.
Actually, what is it
appropriate to this system
is that my epsilon of
p was velocity times p.
But then I started to move
with this superfluid velocity.
Actually, maybe I'll
call this c so that I
a distinction between c, which
is the linear spectrum here,
and the superfluid
velocity dot p.
No, this is actually
a vectorial product.
And because of that,
I only drew one part
of this curve that corresponds
to positive momentum.
If I had gone to
negative momentum,
actually, this curve
would have continued
and whereas one branch
the energy is reduced,
if I go to minus p,
the energy goes up.
So whereas if the
superfluid was not moving,
I can generate as many
excitations with momentum p
as momentum minus p.
Once the superfluid is
moving, there is a difference.
One of them has a v dot p.
The other has minus v dot p.
So because of that,
there is a net momentum
that is carried by
these excitations.
This net momentum is
obtained by summing
over all of these
things, multiplying
with appropriate momentum.
So I have beta is CP
minus v dot p minus 1.
This is the momentum
of the excitation.
This is the net momentum of
the system for one excitation.
But then I have to sum
over all possible P's.
Sum over P's, as
we've discussed,
I can replace with an integral.
And sum over k be replaced with
V. Integral over K, K and P
are simply related
by a factor of h bar.
So whereas before for k I
had 2 pi cubed for v cubed,
I have 2 pi h bar cubed.
So this is what I
have to calculate.
Now what happens for small v?
I can make an expansion
in vs. The 0 order term
in the expansion
is what we would
have for non-moving fluid.
Momenta in the two
directions are the same,
so that contribution goes away.
The first contribution
that I'm going to get
is going to come from expanding
this to lowest order in P.
So there is a P that
is sitting out front.
When I make the
expansion, I will
get a vs dot P
times the derivative
of the exponential
function gives me
a factor of beta
e to the beta CP.
And down here I will have e to
the beta CP minus 1 squared.
Now, in the problem set you
have to actually evaluate
this integral.
It's not that difficult.
It's related to Zeta functions.
But what I'm really
only interested in what
is the temperature dependence?
You can see that I can rescale
this combination, call it x.
Essentially what it says is that
whenever I see a factor of p,
replace it by Kt over Cx.
And how many P's do I have?
I have three, four, five.
So I have five factors of P. So
I will have five factors of Kt.
One of them gets
killed by the beta,
so this whole thing
is proportional to T
to the fourth power.
So what have we found?
We have found that as
this fluid is moving
at some finite
temperature T, it will
generate these excitations.
And these excitations
are preferably
along the direction
of the momentum.
And they correspond to
an additional momentum
of the fluid that is
proportional to the volume.
It's proportional to temperature
to the fourth and something.
And of course, proportional
to the velocity.
Now, we are used to thinking of
the proportionality of momentum
and velocity to be
some kind of a mass.
If I divide that
mass by the volume,
I have a density of
these excitations.
And what we have established
is that the density
of those excitations
is proportional to t
to the fourth.
And what is happening in this
Andronikashvili experiment
is that as these plates are
moving, by this mechanism
the superfluid
that is in contact
with them will
create excitations.
And the momentum of
those excitations
would correspond to some
kind of a density that
vanishes as T to
the fourth, again
in agreement with
what we've seen here.
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So in an
integral expression
you have vs as part
of a dot product.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And then in the
next line [INAUDIBLE].
So it's in that direction.
PROFESSOR: So let's give these
indices p in direction alpha.
This is p in direction alpha.
This is v in direction
beta, p in direction
beta, sum over beta.
Now, I have to do an
angular integration that
is spherically symmetric.
And then somewhere inside
there it has a p alpha p beta.
That angular
integration will give me
a p squared over three delta
alpha beta, which then converts
this v beta to a
b alpha, which is
in the direction
of the momentum.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Will
you say once again
what happened to the
integral dimension?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So when we are in the
Bose-Einstein condensate,
as far as the
excitations of concerned
we have zero chemical potential.
Whatever number of
particle that we
have in excess of what
can be accommodated
through the excitations we put
together in the ground state.
So if you like the ground
state, the kp equals to 0
or k equals to 0,
is a reservoir.
You can add as many
particles there
or bring as many particles
out of it as you like.
So effectively, you have
no conservation number
and no need for a [? z. ?]
Of course, that we
only know for the case
of the true
Bose-Einstein condensate.
We are kind of
jumping and giving
that concept relevance for
the interacting superfluid.
OK?
Any other questions?
So this is actually
the last item
I wanted to cover for
going on the board.
The rest of the hour,
we have this movie
that I had promised you.
I will let that movie run.
I also have all the connection
of problem sets, and exams,
and test that you
have not picked up.
So while the movie runs, you
are welcome to sit and enjoy it.
It's very nice.
Or you can go and take your
stuff and go your own way
or do whatever you like.
So let's go back.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: There
will be more action.
-We just made a transfer
from liquid helium
out of the storage tank into
our own experimental equipment.
It is a remarkable [INAUDIBLE].
It has two different and
easily distinguishable
liquid phases-- a
warmer and a colder one.
The warmer phase is called
liquid helium I and the colder
phase liquid helium II.
The two stages are separated
by a transition temperature,
known as the lambda point.
When liquid helium is pulled
down through the lambda point,
a transition from helium I to
helium II is clearly visible.
We will show it to you
later in this film.
The two liquids behave nothing
like any other known liquid,
although it could be said that
helium I, the warmer phase,
approximates the behavior
of common liquids.
But it is helium II,
the colder phase,
which is truly different.
Because of this, it is
called a superfluid.
The temperatures involved when
working with liquid helium
are quite low.
Helium boils at
4.2 degrees Kelvin
under conditions of
atmospheric pressure.
And the lambda point lies
at roughly 2.2 degrees.
Note that this
corresponds to minus 269
and minus 271
degrees centigrade.
The properties of liquid
helium that I have just
been telling you about
are characteristic
of the heavy isotope
if helium, helium-4.
The element occurs in the
form of two stable isotopes.
[INAUDIBLE] The second
and lighter one,
helium-3, is very rare.
Its abundance is only
about 1 part of 10 million.
Pure liquid helium-3
is the subject
of intensive study
at the present time,
but so far no second
superfluid liquid phase
has been found to
exist for helium-3.
The low temperature at
which we'll be working
calls for well-insulated
containers.
The dewar meets
our requirements.
The word "dewar" is
a scientific name
given to a double-walled
vessel with the space
between the walls evacuated.
When these dewars
are made of glass,
the surface of this
inner space is usually
filtered to cut down heat
transfer by radiation.
However, our dewars will
have to be transparent
so that we can look at
what's going on inside.
Now, liquid helium is commonly
stored in double dewars.
The design is quite
simple, just put one
inside the other like this.
In the inner dewar, we
put the liquid helium,
and in the space between
the inner and outer dewar,
we maintain a supply
of liquid air.
Here is a double dewar
exactly like the one
we will be using in our
demonstration experiment.
The inner dewar is filled
with liquid helium.
The outer dewar
contains liquid air.
The normal boiling
temperature of liquid air
is about 80 degrees
Kelvin, 75 or more degrees
hotter than liquid helium.
The purpose of the
liquid air is twofold.
First, we put the liquid air
in the outer dewar well ahead
of putting liquid helium
in the inner dewar.
In this way, the inner
dewar is pre-cooled.
Secondly, we maintain
a supply of liquid air
in the outer dewar
because it provides
an additional
[INAUDIBLE] of insulation
now that the liquid helium
is in the inner dewar.
The [INAUDIBLE] liquid
air attests to the fact
that it is absorbing
some of the heat which
enters the double dewar.
Even with the boiling
of the liquid air,
the liquid helium
is clearly visible.
Later, we will use
liquid air cooled
below its boiling temperature
to reduce or eliminate
the air bubbles for
better visibility.
Now the liquid
air is cooled down
and we have eliminated boiling.
The smaller bubbles of
the boiling liquid helium
are clearly visible.
The cover over the inner dewar
has a port, at present open.
The liquid helium is at
atmospheric pressure,
so its temperature is
4.2 degrees Kelvin.
In other words, what
we have in here now
is liquid helium one, the
warmer of the two phases.
Before we cool it down to take
a look at the superfluid phase,
I want to dwell greatly on the
properties of helium I. I've
told you before
that even helium I
is different from
the normal liquids.
The distance between neighboring
atoms and this liquid
is quite large.
The atoms are not
as closely packed
as in the classical liquids.
The reason for this
is quantum mechanics.
The zero point energy is
relatively more important
here than in any other liquid.
As a consequence,
liquid helium has
a very low mass density, only
about 13% the density of water,
and a very low optical density.
The index of refraction
is quite close to 1.
This makes its surface hard
to see with the naked eye
under ordinary
lighting conditions.
You are no doubt
familiar with the fact
that the helium atom has
closed shell atomic structure.
This explains why helium is
a chemically inert element.
It also accounts for the fact
that the force of attraction
between neighboring helium
atoms, the so-called van der
Waals force, is small.
It takes little energy to
pull two helium atoms apart,
as for example in evaporation.
This gives liquid helium
a better small latent
heat of vaporization.
Only five calories are
needed to evaporate one gram.
Compare this with water,
where evaporation requires
between 500 and 600
calories per gram.
The low van der Waals force
combined with a large zero
point energy also accounts for
the fact that liquid helium
does not freeze, cannot
be solidified at ordinary
pressure, no matter
how far we cool it.
However, liquid helium has been
solidified at high pressure.
The liquid helium in the
dewar is at 4,2 degrees.
We now want to cool it
down to the lambda point
and show you the transition
to the [INAUDIBLE].
Our method will be
cooling by evaporation
using a vacuum pump.
Now, the lambda point lies at
2.2 degrees, only 2 degrees
colder than the [INAUDIBLE]
temperature of the liquid.
What's more, not
very much heat has
been removed from
the liquid helium
now in the dewar to bring
it to the lambda point.
It amounts to only
about 250 calories.
Nevertheless, don't get the
idea that this cooling process
is easy.
On the contrary,
it's quite difficult.
More than 1/3 of the liquid
helium now in the dewar
has to be knocked
away in vapor form
before we can get what remains
behind to the lambda point.
That requires an
awful lot of pumping
and explains why we use this
large and powerful vacuum
pump over here.
Even with this pump,
the cooling process
takes a considerable
amount of time.
Let me explain why
it is so difficult
to cool liquid helium
to the lambda point.
I have already mentioned
that liquid helium has
a remarkably small
[INAUDIBLE] vaporization,
only five calories per gram.
At the same time, liquid
helium at 4.2 degrees
has a high specific heat,
almost calorie per gram.
Therefore, 1 gram of
the vapor pumped away
carries with it
an amount of heat
which can cool only 5 or 6 grams
of liquid helium by 1 degree.
That's not very much cooling.
It is less by a
factor of almost 100
than when we cool
water by evaporation.
The situation gets even
worse as cooling progresses
below 4.2 degrees because the
specific heat of liquid helium
rises astonishingly.
As we approach 2,17
degrees, the lambda point.
The heat of vaporization,
on the other hand,
remains roughly the same.
So a given amount
of vapor carried
off produces less
and less cooling
as we approach 2.17 degrees,
Our thermometer here
is a low pressure gauge
connected to the space
above the liquid helium.
The needle registers
the pressure there.
It is the saturated vapor
pressure of liquid helium.
The gauge is calibrated for
the corresponding temperature.
We call it a vapor
pressure thermometer.
As we approach 2.17
degrees, boiling
becomes increasingly violent.
Suddenly it stops.
This was the transition.
The liquid you now
see is helium II.
Even though evaporation does
continue, there is no boiling.
The normal liquids, such
as the water in this basin,
boil because of their relatively
low heat conductivity.
Before heat,
[INAUDIBLE] at one point
can be carried away
to a cooler place
in the liquid bubbles
of the vapor form.
Helium I behaves like a
normal liquid in this respect.
The absence of
boiling in helium II
reveals that this
phase acts as if it
had a large heat conductivity.
As a matter of fact, as
the liquid helium passed
through the lambda
point transition
you just saw, its
heat conductivity
increased by the fantastic
factor of one million.
The heat conductivity of
helium II is many times
greater than in the
metals silver and copper,
which are among the best
solid heat conductors.
And yet here we
deal with a liquid.
For this alone,
helium II deserves
the name of superfluid.
Actually, the way in
which helium II transports
such large quantities
of heat so rapidly
is totally different from
the classical concept
for heat conduction.
I'll come back to
the subject later
in connection with an
experiment demonstrating
the phenomenon of second
sound in helium II.
Remember that this great
change in heat conductivity
occurred at a single
and fixed transition
temperature, the lambda point.
We do indeed deal with
a change in phase,
only here it is a change from
one liquid to another liquid.
As we told you before, the
specific heat of liquid helium
is very large as a lambda point.
In fact, it behaves abnormally
even below the lambda point
and falls again very rapidly
with the temperature.
This discontinuity
in specific heat
is another reflection
of the fact
that we are dealing
with a change
in the phase of the substance.
By the way, the curve resembles
the Greek letter lambda.
The transition
temperature got its name
from the shape of this curve.
[INAUDIBLE]
The next one has to do with
the viscosity of liquid helium.
When a normal liquid
flows through a tube,
it will resist the flow.
In this experiment, we
shall cause some glycerin
to flow to a tube
under its own weight.
The top layer is
colored glycerin.
The liquid layer closest to
the tube wall adheres to it.
The layer next in from the one
touching the wall flows by it
and is retarded as it flows due
to the interatomic, the van der
Waals force of attraction.
The second layer in
turn drags on the third,
and so on inward from the
wall, producing fluid friction,
or viscosity.
The narrower the
tube, the slower
the liquid rate
of flow through it
under a given head of pressure.
Here I have a beaker with
an unglazed ceramic bottom
of ultra-fine [INAUDIBLE].
Many capillary channels run
through this ceramic disk.
The diameter is quite small,
about one micron which is
1/10,000 of a centimeter.
There is liquid
helium in the beaker.
It is 4.2 degrees Kelvin,
helium I, the normal phase.
The capillaries in the
disk are fine enough
to prevent the liquid now in
the beaker from flowing through
under its on weight.
Clearly, helium I is viscous.
To be sure, its
viscosity is very small.
That's why we had to choose
extremely fine capillaries
to demonstrate it.
Here you see the lambda
point transition.
The helium II all poured out.
The rate of pouring would
not be noticeably slower
if the [INAUDIBLE]
were made yet finer.
We call this kind
of flow a superflow.
The temperature is
now at 1.6 degrees.
The superflow is even faster.
The viscosity of helium
II in this experiment
is so small that it has
not been possible to find
a value for it.
It is less than the experimental
uncertainty incurred
in attempts to measure it.
We now believe that
helium II, the superfluid,
has zero viscosity, although
we should be more precise here.
We believe its viscosity is zero
when observing capillary flow.
Bear this statement
in mind, for we
will come up with a
contradiction to it
in the next experiment,
where we will
look for viscosity by
a different method.
There is a copper cylinder
in the liquid helium,
so mounted as we can turn
it about a vertical axis.
In order to turn it smoothly
and with as little vibration as
possible, we laid the
cylinder into the [INAUDIBLE]
of a simple induction
motor energized
from outside the dewar.
The four horizontal
coils you see
provide the torque which
turns the cylinder.
The liquid helium is
electrically non-conducting.
The coil exerts no
torque on it directly.
Yet as we turn on our
motor, the liquid layer
bounding the cylinder is
dragged along behind it.
The boundary layer in turn
drags on the next layer,
and so on outward.
Finally a circulation
showing up in the helium
due to its own viscosity and
the wooden panels we [INAUDIBLE]
is turned along.
What we have just seen
occurred in helium I,
the normal phase at
4.2 degrees Kelvin.
That is to say,
this demonstration
is consistent with our results
for helium I by capillary flow.
Helium I is viscous.
Here you see the liquid
cooled down and passing
into the superfluid
phase, helium II.
Let's turn on the motor.
The paddle wheel starts again.
What does this mean?
First of all, let me
emphasize that, like helium I,
helium II is also non-conducting
in the electrical sense.
In other words, the
circulation in the experiment
can only have been caused
through viscous drag.
So we conclude from the
rotating cylinder observations
that helium II is viscous
and from the method
of capillary flow that
it has zero viscosity.
Our experimentation has
come up with a paradox.
No normal classical
liquid is known
to behave so inconsistently, in
capillary flow on the one hand
and in bulk flow on the other.
This state of affairs
forces us to think
of helium II, the
superfluid, not as a single,
but as a dual liquid.
It appeared as if helium
II had two separate and yet
interpenetrating
component liquids.
We shall call one
component normal.
It is this component
which we call
responsible for the
appearance of viscosity
below the lambda point in the
rotating cylinder experiment.
The normal component,
as the name suggests,
behaves like a normal liquid,
and therefore as viscosity.
It is the one which the cylinder
drags along as its turned.
But the normal components
cannot flow through the narrow
channels of the ceramic disc
because of its viscosity.
The second component
has zero viscosity,
and it's called the
superfluid component.
We think that it does
not participate at all
in the rotating cylinder
experiment below the lambda
point.
It stays at rest.
On the other hand, it can flow
through channels of one micron
diameter with the greatest
of ease and countering
no resistance whatever
because it has no viscosity.
As we'll see later, this
flow is not repeated even
when the capillary
diameters are made
far smaller than one micron.
This [INAUDIBLE] construction
is called the two fluid
model for liquid helium II.
Whether it is correct
or not depends
on further tests
comparing the theory
based on this model with
experimental results.
We now go on to another
phenomenon, the fountain
effect.
What you see here
is a tube which
narrows down and then
opens into a bulb.
A small piece of cotton is
stuffed into the [INAUDIBLE]
section between the
tube and the bulb.
And the bulb has been tightly
packed with one of the finest
powders available, [INAUDIBLE].
And second wad of cotton
keeps the powder in the bulb.
This powder presents extremely
fine capillary channels.
Their average diameter is a
small fraction of 1 micron.
This device has been
placed in the dewar.
The liquid helium is
below the lambda point.
We submerge the bulb, and then
we'll send a beam of light
from this lamp to a
point near the top.
You will see the light beam
when the lamp is turned on.
It focuses some heat in the
form of infrared radiation
on the point in question.
The temperature will rise
above the temperature
of the rest of the apparatus.
Let us turn it on.
Liquid helium flows through the
hole in the bottom of the bulb,
through the fine
powder, and rises
above the level of
liquid helium outside.
The height to which
it will go depends
on the temperature
increase produced
bu the lamp focused on the bulb.
We can very well ask, where
does the mechanical energy
come from that does the
work necessary to pump
the liquid above
the ambient level?
Before we attempt to
discuss this question,
there are two other facts
that should be noted.
The first is by now obvious.
The upward flow through the bulb
must clearly be a superfluid.
Only the superfluid component
of helium II could get through.
The second fact is
more significant.
Let me explain it this way, the
superfluid flows spontaneously
from a to b,from a
cooler to a warmer place.
Point a is in the
cold liquid, but b
is being heated
with infrared rays.
The second law of thermodynamics
positively says that heat
cannot of itself flow from
a point of lower to a point
of higher temperature.
What does this mean
to us here, knowing
as we do that the
superfluid is flowing
from a colder to a warmer spot?
Simply this, it carries no
heat, no thermal energy.
Any internal energy
[INAUDIBLE] is no longer
thermally available.
To say it precisely,
it has zero entropy.
We have discovered another
remarkable property
of helium II.
Its superfluid component
not only is friction free,
it also contains no heat.
The heat energy
contained in helium II
as a whole resides, all of
it, in the normal component.
We may, of course, add heat
to the superfluid component,
as we are doing when it passes
the spot heated by the lamp.
But in doing so, we
are converting it
into the normal component.
Let me return briefly to
a question posed earlier.
Mechanical work is done
in pumping the liquid
above equilibrium level.
Where does it come from?
I cannot answer this
question here in full,
but it suffice to tell you that
we are dealing here with a heat
engine.
The mechanical energy
comes from the heat
added at the light spot.
An amusing demonstration
of the same phenomenon
again uses a bulb
packed with rouge,
but this one opens
into a capillary.
Light is beamed on a spot
just below the capillary,
and it produces a
helium fountain.
The phenomenon in this and
the previous experiment
has become known as
the thermomechanical,
or the fountain, effect.
Below the lambda point,
the superfluid component
of liquid helium creeps
up along the walls
of its container in an
extremely thin film.
It is known as a Rollin film.
This creeping film is
a variety of superflow.
It is difficult to make the film
itself directly visible to you.
To show it indirectly,
we've put some liquid helium
into a glass vessel.
It is below the lambda point.
There is no part porous
bottom in this vessel.
The film rises along
the inside wall
and comes down
along the outside,
collecting in drops
at the bottom.
The thickness of
this creeping film
is only a small fraction of
1 micron and of the order
of 200 to 300 angstrom.
Its speed, while small just
below the lambda point,
may reach a value as
high as 35 centimeters
per second at
lower temperatures.
Our next experiment deals with
the phenomenon of second sound.
We are all familiar with wave
motion in elastic materials,
be they solids,
liquids, or gases.
Elastic energy of deformation,
carried away from its source
in the form of waves with
a characteristic speed,
the speed of sound.
Liquid helium is an
elastic substance
both above and below
the lambda point.
Both helium one and two
support sound waves.
Now helium II, the
superfluid phase,
also conducts heat
in the form of waves.
This remarkable property is
shared by no other substance.
For better or for worse, it
has been called second sound.
Normal heat conduction
is a diffusion process.
The rate of flow of heat is
proportional to the temperature
differences.
But in helium II it
is a wave process.
Heat flows through helium II
with a characteristic speed,
the speed of second sound.
We shall send small heat pulses
into helium II from a heater.
They will spread away
from the heater uniformly,
carrying the heat
energy with them.
The speed of second
sound is small just
below the lambda point.
In the neighborhood
of 1.6 degrees Kelvin,
it reaches a value of
roughly 20 meters per second,
and it is in this range that
we will run our demonstration.
The experimental
procedure is as follows.
There are two disks
in the liquid helium.
They are carbon resistors
with the carbon applied
in thin layers on one
side of each disk.
In this way, good
thermal contact
is established between the
resistor and the liquid helium.
The following resistor
will be used as a heater.
Electric currents will
be sent through it
in pulses from this pulse
generator by means of the cable
you see here.
The [INAUDIBLE] of
the generator is also
connected via a second cable
to a dual-trace oscilloscope,
where it will be recorded
on the bottom [? trip. ?]
In other words, it will record
the heat pulse as it enters
the liquid helium.
The pulses have been turned on.
They themselves trigger
the horizontal sweep
of [INAUDIBLE], which
records [INAUDIBLE].
It is calibrated
at 1 millisecond
per unit on the scale.
The pulses are 1
millisecond long.
The pulses leave the
heater at the bottom
in the form of
second sound and move
up to where they strike the
carbon resistor at the top.
Being heat pulses, they
greatly raise is temperature.
The carbon resistor is
quite sensitive to changes
in temperature.
It acts as a thermometer.
So the heat pulse
of second sound
creates a pulse-like
change in the resistance
of the [INAUDIBLE] up here.
It isn't hard to
convert this resistance
pulse into a [INAUDIBLE].
What we will do is to
maintain a small DC
current in the top resistor.
It is supplied from a
battery in this metal box.
The box shields the
circuits in order
to reduce electronic noise.
The voltage pulse is small.
In this second box
we have an amplifier.
The amplified output is fed
into the oscilloscope, where
it will appear on
the upper trace.
The horizontal
timescale on this trace
is exactly the same as
for the bottom trace.
However, the upper trace
records both exchanges
as they occur in
the top resistor,
a detector of second sound.
The temperature of the liquid
is about 1.65 degrees Kelvin.
The battery has been turned
on, and now the amplifier.
Among noise and other
distortions in the upper trace,
a clear-cut voltage pulse
appears about 4 and 1/2 units
to the right, 4 and
1/2 milliseconds later
than the pulse
entering the heater.
This pulse in the upper trace is
also about 1 millisecond long.
It is the second sound as it
arrives at the upper resistor.
The upper trace also shows
a strong voltage pulse
at the left, simultaneous
to the heater pulse.
That's due to pick-up
by electromagnetic waves
with the heater acting as
transmitter and the detector
as receiver.
We're moving the detector
toward the heater.
The pulse moves
with it to the left.
Notice the echos of second sound
which appear on the upper trace
while the detector
is near the heater.
They're caused by multiple
reflections between the two
resistors.
A total of three echos
is clearly visible.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: OK, you can watch
the rest of it at home.